[Musik]
Deutschland wird ärmer
wir verlieren gerade in Milliarden
Größenordnung jeden Tag Wohlstand
der Kanzler versucht das Land mit einem
Versprechen zu beruhigen
you never walk alone und das ist auch
das was wir tun
die Krise ist ein Wettlauf gegen die
Zeit woher bekommen wir Energie wie viel
ist unser Geld noch wert wo sind die
Fachkräfte wie rüsten wir Deutschland
für die Zukunft man muss sich klar
machen dass wir in einer hoch
angespannten Phase der deutschen
Geschichte agieren und leben dass wir in
Teilen auch für die Nachlässigkeit die
Vergesslichkeit die Gleichgültigkeit der
Vergangenheit jetzt einen Preis bezahlen
waren die vergangenen Jahrzehnte nur auf
samt gebaut gewisser Weise war das von
heute aus gesehen eine paradiesische
Zeit und ist vorbei
und jetzt taucht die Frage auf was kommt
denn jetzt wer zahlt eigentlich für die
Kosten dieser Krise die Herausforderung
gerade ist er dass wir uns gar nicht
vorstellen könnten dass unser Wohlstand
mal zur Disposition steht und dass wir
uns echt anstrengen müssen
[Musik]
Deutschland im Herbst 2022 das ist ein
verunsichertes Land
definitiv jetzt gerade eine Zeit wo wir
auch vor allen Dingen junge Leute wenig
Optionen haben also ich kann mir jetzt
kein Haus kaufen oder kann für meine
Kind groß vorsorgen ich würde schon
behaupten dass die Mittelschicht nicht
unbedingt reicher wird ich bin nun eine
Generation die schon Knappheit kennt da
war ich zwar klein aber ich kann mich
gut erinnern
das wollen wir eigentlich nicht noch mal
haben
es ist das Versprechen von Wohlstand und
Wachstum auf dem unsere
nachkriegsdemokratie aufgebaut ist das
System
aus dem Chaos heraus wenn
wirtschaftlichen und sozialen
Wiederaufbau begannen wird uns auch in
Zukunft erfolgreich
was jetzt ganz ganz neu ist ist dass es
eben nicht wie nach 45 darum geht es
wird uns immer besser gehen die Zeit
läuft für uns was wir jetzt haben ist
wir werden Verluste erleiden wir sind
auf einem ganz ganz hohen Niveau von dem
wir irgendwie runterkommen werden der
drohende Wohlstandsverlust macht den
Menschen in Deutschland Angst für diesen
Film wurden über 1.000 Bundesbürger
befragt die Ergebnisse sind
repräsentativ 43 Prozent rechnen mit
einer Verschlechterung ihrer
wirtschaftlichen Lage
die Stimmung zwingt auch die Regierung
zum Handeln
die Ampelkoalition wollte das Land
erneuern jetzt schüttet sie vor allem
Geld auf die größten Probleme
200 Milliarden das ist eine imposante
Summe eine Vision für Deutschland ist es
nicht
man kann sagen dass es hier ein
doppelbums man könnte fast sagen dass es
eine Art befriedungspolitik gewesen ist
es sind diese drei die Deutschland durch
die Krise führen der grüne Vizekanzler
der das Land klimaneutraler machen
wollte der Finanzminister von der FDP
der das Land moderner machen wollte und
der sozialdemokratische Kanzler der das
Land gerechter machen wollte jeder hat
eine andere Botschaft ich bin fest davon
überzeugt dass unser Land
Zuversicht braucht dieses Land wird
Zumutungen tragen müssen die Zeit des
Verteilens des einmal erwirtschafteten
Wohlstands ist beendet getrieben wird
die Regierung auch von ihm Friedrich
Merz Oppositionsführer Chef der CDU
dessen Partei den Grund der Krise
mitzuverantworten hat die Abhängigkeit
von Putins Gas das nicht mehr fließt
am Anfang einer Rezession und wie die
über den Winter verläuft zusammen mit
der
Energieverknappung mit der prekären Lage
vieler privater Haushalte mit der
Existenznot
des Mittelstandes
also das hat
schon Zutaten für einen ziemlichen Sturm
ein Sturm der sich für die Menschen in
Deutschland bislang vor allem an
steigenden Preisen festmacht
die Preise sind alle höher gegangen und
ich kann das mir nicht mehr leisten ich
mache mir sehr viel Gedanken ums
finanzielle einfach wie komme ich über
die Runden wo kann ich was einspannen
so voll mit Kohle und unser einer muss
am Hunger
schokoladenkante aber jetzt mit seiner
Inflation ne wenn es jetzt wenn das
wirklich kommt dann ist das Geld fort
und Leute die keine Rücklagen haben was
machen die dann also ich finde das schon
krass
laut dem Deutschen Institut für
Wirtschaftsforschung haben 40 Prozent
der Deutschen keine Rücklagen sie werden
besonders hart getroffen von der
Inflation seit Putins Angriff auf die
Ukraine steigen die Preise so stark wie
seit den 50er Jahren nicht mehr die
Inflation liegt jetzt bei über 10
Prozent in unserer repräsentativen
Umfrage berichten 41% der Menschen dass
sie sich deshalb bereits stark oder sehr
stark einschränken Inflation ist das
größte Gift
Inflation zerstört das was Menschen sich
über Jahrzehnte erspart und aufgebaut
haben Inflation zerstört die Anreize
auch zu investieren weil man keine
Sicherheit hat das bedeutet einfach dass
nun der Wohlstandsverlust ganz ganz
deutlich wird an den Ladenkassen
Berlin-Neukölln Camilla weiß ist auf dem
Weg zum Supermarkt die gebürtige Polin
arbeitet als Reinigungskraft im
Krankenhaus
mitterteuer Strom teuer gastheuer
ich sehe einfach meine Geld nicht mehr
ich arbeite ganz im Monat durch und
trotzdem meine Geld einfach reicht nicht
für normales Leben
die alleinerziehende verdient im Monat
1600 Euro netto dazu kommt Kindergeld
für die Tochter
ein Paket früher hatte gekostet weiß ich
nicht
2 Euro 19 2 Euro 20 ein Euro 99 jetzt
kostet schon
3,49 Euro ich ganz ehrlich ich gehe von
Angebot bis zum Angebot weil sonst kann
ich noch nicht das leisten
der subjektive Eindruck von Camilla weiß
trügt nicht viele Lebensmittel sind
teurer geworden Butter kostete im
Oktober 55% mehr als im Vorjahr Gemüse
23 Prozent Fleisch 19 Brot ebenfalls 19
und auch Bier war 10% teurer
die Angst vor Armut treibt Menschen auf
die Straße wie bei dieser gewerkschafts-
[Applaus]
beschlossen 200 Milliarden wollen sie
uns irgendwie zur Verfügung stellen wann
sollen denn die 200 Milliarden ankommen
und bei wem denn bitteschön wir bei den
großen Konzernen oder mal ganz unten
hier für euch
der Winter steht vor der Tür ich brauche
keine Winterreifen im Sommer ich
brauchte jetzt jetzt und sind für alle
für jung für Mittelalter und für die
Rentner für alle müssen umverteilt
werden
in unserer Umfrage sagen 74% der
deutschen das jetzt vor allem vermögende
die Hilfen bezahlen sollen
eine Art von ganz grundsätzlichen
gesellschaftlichen Vertrag bröckelt wenn
Menschen das Gefühl haben dass sie sich
ein Grundbedürfnis wie heizen mit ihrem
wirtschafteten nicht mehr leisten können
dann kann die Situation entstehen in der
ein Grundvertrauen in die Gesellschaft
und die Wirtschaft anfängt brüchig zu
werden und ich glaube wir sind an so
einem Punkt
Hannover Anfang Oktober 2022 einen Tag
vor der Landtagswahl in Niedersachsen
der Kanzler ist da und versucht den
Zusammenhalt zu beschwören
wir werden alles dafür tun dass die
Preise wieder runtergehen mit
strompreisbremsen und gaspreisbremsen
wir werden die ganze Kraft unseres
Staates zusammenführen und wir werden
Solidarität miteinander ausüben
mehr Verteilungsgerechtigkeit das ist
eine sozialdemokratische Idee die Olaf
Scholz in seiner Koalition offenbar
nicht durchsetzen kann die SPD hat ein
Wahlprogramm das mir sehr gefallen hat
oder Bundestagswahl geschrieben in dem
wir genau sagen dass wir finden dass
diejenigen die sehr sehr hohe Einkommen
haben die ein paar hunderttausend Euro
verdienen sehr wohl auch einen größeren
Beitrag zu Finanzierung des Gemeinwesens
leisten können wir haben vieles von dem
was wir uns vorgenommen haben
hinbekommen an dieser Frage hat die
Koalition sich entschieden dass sie das
nicht gemeinsam verfolgt
er ist in dieser Koalition der der
Umverteilung nicht will auch Christian
Lindner macht in Niedersachsen Wahlkampf
meine Sorge ist nichts nicht die ganz
besonders Bedürftigen weil die werden
vom Staat versorgt meine Sorge ist die
Arbeiten die Mitte die Menschen die
selbst ihre Gasrechnung zahlen die 40
50.000 Euro verdienen weil sie hart
arbeiten das Gefühl haben könnten eine
Regierung tut nichts für sie Lindner
sieht sich gern als strenger
Vermögensverwalter der deutschen
[Musik]
200 Milliarden Euro die werden von ihnen
zurückgezahlt werden müssen
Linden ist Dilemma der liberale
Finanzminister will eigentlich dass der
Staat keine neuen Schulden macht und
musste doch in kurzer Amtszeit schon
Milliardenkredite auf den Weg bringen
in Wahrheit ist natürlich der
Schuldenberg in diesem Jahr 2022
gewachsen wie nie zuvor wenn ich nur mal
addiere klimafond 60 Milliarden
Bundeswehr 100 Milliarden Sondervermögen
jetzt für Gas und strompreisdeckel noch
mal 200 Milliarden dann sind wir alleine
dabei schon bei
360 Milliarden Euro zusätzlicher
Schulden
3 Oktober 2022
in Luxemburg treffen sich die
Finanzminister der Euro-Staaten
Christian Lindner muss auch hier den
doppelbums erklären vom deutschen
Alleingang ist die Rede
von einem Wettlauf den Deutschland in
Europa anzettelt wer tut am meisten für
die eigenen Bürger gemessen an der Größe
und der Proportion unserer
Volkswirtschaft und unsere Abhängigkeit
ist das eine angemessene Größenordnung
für die Jahre 22 bis 24 die Vorhaltung
wir würden gewissermaßen zu viel machen
und den Wettbewerb verzerren sind
jedenfalls nicht begründet in Zahlen
also aus europäischer Sicht ist es so
Deutschland hat Deutschland ist
ursächlich für die Krise verantwortlich
Deutschland hat sich nicht ausreichend
beteiligt bei den
preisdämpfungsmechanismen und jetzt
kauft es sich wieder raus aus der Krise
mit Geld dass wir anderen Länder nicht
haben eine neue Finanzkrise das ist
jetzt das Ziel doch die Macht der
Politik über die globalen Geldmärkte ist
beschränkt
ganz oben im Hochhaus der Europäischen
Zentralbank in Frankfurt findet alle
sechs Wochen eine Sitzung statt die über
das auf- und Ab der Finanzmärkte
entscheidet und letztlich darüber wie
viel unser Geld noch wert ist
es ist ein Ritual auf die Minute genau
um 14 Uhr gibt Präsidentin Christin
Lagarde bekannt ob die Leitzinsen
verändert werden an diesem Tag Ende
Oktober 2022 verkündet sie eine Erhöhung
um 0,75%
wir tun was getan werden muss als
Zentralbank konzentrieren wir uns auf
unser Mandat Preisstabilität dazu müssen
wir alle uns zur Verfügung stehenden
Werkzeuge so sinnvoll und effizient wie
möglich einsetzen das machen wir heute
mit dieser Zinserhöhung
das Ziel der EZB die Inflation von 10
auf 2% zu drücken wenn wir die Zinsen
erhöhen dann
verschlechtern sich die
Finanzierungsbedingungen das heißt
Kredite werden teurer das hat ein
dämpfenden Einfluss auf die Nachfrage
und deshalb hat das dann eine dämpfende
Auswirkung auf die Inflation allerdings
dauert das bis sich das Ganze in der
Wirtschaft dann tatsächlich durchsetzt
Privatleute spüren die Auswirkungen
schon jetzt laden die Zinsen für einen
Hauskredit im Februar noch bei etwas
über einem Prozent sind es jetzt schon
fast vier die Sparzinsen dagegen haben
Banken bisher nur unwesentlich erhöht
und verdienen so gutes Geld
[Applaus]
unterwegs in Brandenburg westlich von
Berlin fährt Makler mariustummelei zu
einer seiner Immobilien
[Musik]
die Dozenten Anzahl hat sich zum größten
Teil halbiert Leute die sich vorher noch
von einem halben Jahr Immobilien von 7
800.000 Euro 7 800.000 Euro leisten
konnten die Rutschen einfach aufgrund
der Zinserhöhung der steigenden
Lebenserhaltungskosten in eine andere
Sparte und das ist natürlich für viele
KO-Kriterium mittlerweile sogar ja
einige Leute müssen wirklich Abstand vom
vom
Traum der der eigenen Immobilie Abstand
nehmen
[Musik]
in Brieselang bei Falkensee verkauft der
Makler ein Haus aus den 1990ern
eigentlich hatte er schon Käufer
gefunden Familie ögel aus Berlin doch
durch die steigenden Zinsen wird der
Hauskredit immer teurer ist absolut ein
blödes Gefühl also ich meine
es ist schon länger auf jeden Fall ein
Traum und wir sind beide jemand der sehr
fleißig ist viel arbeiten gehen und
das ist absolut einfach hat keine
relation
ist nicht ist nicht schön
die Rezeptionistin und der Maler
verdienen monatlich über 4.500 Euro
netto und gehören damit zur
Mittelschicht doch der Traum vom
Eigenheim rückt für Menschen wie sie
gerade in weite Ferne
sie muss ein Limit von
1.500 bis wer hat 2000 Euro war schon
wirklich dann die Schmerzgrenze gewesen
weil wie gesagt leben wollen wir ja auch
mal ein bisschen einmal im Jahr im
Urlaub muss sein 28 3000 würden Sie hier
genau jetzt für diese Haus bezahlen ja
vor einem Jahr lang hier bei dem bei dem
Haus vielleicht aber 1500 Euro rate
1500 bis 1800 also hat sich verdoppelt
kann man praktisch sagen tja so ist das
der Haustraum für die ögels ist er
vorerst geplatzt wir halten jetzt
erstmal die Beine still ja weil ändern
können wir so oder so nicht jetzt so von
daher abgefunden haben uns damit noch
nicht also ich meine wir sind noch neben
Alter wo wir das vielleicht stemmen
können aber irgendwann ist der Zug dann
auch abgefahren ja und dann müssen wir
dann vernünftig sein und sagen es geht
nicht und dann geht's halt nicht
in jeder dieser Situation gibt es
Gewinner und Verlierer wir haben
beispielsweise gesehen dass dass die
Kosten zu einem hohen Anteil von den
Arbeitnehmern getragen werden während
wir sehen dass in einer ganzen Reihe von
Unternehmen die Gewinne spürbar
angestiegen sind weil die Unternehmen
letztlich die Zeit genutzt haben ihre
Preise zu erhöhen und zum Teil eben
stärker als ihre Kosten gestiegen sind
laut einer Studie des ifo-Instituts
haben einige Branchen ihre
Verkaufspreise deutlich mehr erhöht als
ihre Kosten gestiegen sind
Landwirte machen so bis zu 60%
übergewinnen beim Baugewerbe sind es 20%
und in Handel und Gastronomie 9%
und auch Energiepreise kennen aktuell
nur eine Richtung nach oben
[Musik]
es macht glaube ich jeder ne dass man
sich Sorgen machen muss eben ein
bisschen aufpassen mit heizen auch und
so ne wir sitzen bei 17 Kreuze und es
ist kalt aus niederfrierst du wir haben
schon Kriege erlebt also wir wissen was
ist das bedeutet was es bedeutet von
unseren Politikern gewünscht dass sie
sich so aufstellen dass sie unabhängig
werden oder nicht so abhängig von
anderen und fremden Ländern und auch
nicht von einem Herrn Putin
jahrzehntelang war günstige Energie wie
Doping für die deutsche Wirtschaft
besonders das pipeline-gas aus Russland
seit Kriegsbeginn in der Ukraine ist
klar dass unsere Energieversorgung
sicher ist das war eine Illusion
seit Februar steigen die Energiepreise
in Deutschland wie nie zuvor vor allem
der Gasmarkt schien zeitweise völlig
außer Kontrolle auch Heizöl kostet
inzwischen fast das Doppelte
Geld das viele nicht haben in unserer
Umfrage geben 63% der Befragten an dass
sie deshalb stark oder sehr stark
Energie einsparen wollen war schon bei
Kriegsbeginn klar dass die Sanktion eine
Wirkung auch auf die deutsche Wirtschaft
haben würden viel stärker für Russland
und jeputin und dass die höheren
Energiepreise natürlich auch auf die
Wirtschaft und auf das Einkommen der
Menschen drücken würden der aktuell ist
meine größte Sorge dass wir mit diesem
massiven Preisanstieg den wir gerade
beim Gas erleben auch relativ viel von
der wirtschaftssubstanz zerstören
für manche Firmen sind die steigenden
Energiepreise eine existenzielle
Bedrohung in Ennepetal am Rand des
Ruhrgebiets produziert die Firma BIW
Dichtungen kabelschutzsysteme und
Schläuche aus Silikon dafür braucht der
europäische Marktführer viel Strom und
Gas
600 Menschen arbeiten in dem
Familienbetrieb Jens Trost schon seit 32
Jahren und muss sich jetzt um seinen Job
Sorgen
wenn wir die wirtschaftliche Entwicklung
wirklich so haben wie wir das sehen also
dass wir in eine Rezession geht werden
wir da zwei oder drei Jahre mit zu tun
haben mit den Entscheidungen die heute
getroffen werden und wir müssen gucken
wie können wir es sicherstellen dass
unsere Versorgung Energie Strom Gas auch
wirklich da ist um halt nicht ein
Sterben der ganzen kleinen
mittelständischen Unternehmen zu haben
BIW hat auch Niederlassungen in China
und in Polen in Deutschland waren die
Energiekosten schon immer höher durch
Innovation und Flexibilität konnte der
Nachteil wettgemacht werden nun soll die
Firma von Ralf Stoffels mindestens 20%
Gas sparen wir als Mittelständler wir
sind von unseren Kunden abhängig ich
kann nicht sagen ich fertige jetzt nur
80 Prozent weil ich sparen möchte
sondern ich muss das liefern was meine
Kunden mir vorgeben dafür sind die
Verträge einfach Tat gerade Richtung
Automobilindustrie das heißt ich kann
nur im Prozessen sparen und das hat
Grenzen das Gespenst der
Deindustrialisierung geht um
die Gefahr steht im Raum dass wir
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit verlieren und dann
nicht mehr in Deutschland investiert
wird sondern dass das Betriebe und damit
die Arbeitsplätze ins Ausland gehen
darauf müssen wir uns jetzt einrichten
Berlin Mitte Oktober 2022 der
Wirtschaftsminister ist zu Gast bei
einer Konferenz von Deutschlands
Maschinenbauern eine energieintensive
Branche mit fast einer Million
Beschäftigten
[Musik]
von Habeck fordern Sie heute das auch
die Strompreise gedeckelt werden im
Kampf gegen die Folgen des energiekriegs
mit Putin kommt der Wirtschaftsminister
kaum hinterher
wir sind in einer wirtschaftsgerischen
Auseinandersetzung das kann man gar
nicht wegreden aber wir haben auch
Mittel uns zu schützen und zu wehren das
haben wir bisher an verschiedenen
Stellen volle Speicher neue
Infrastruktur okay gemacht
manches war nicht okay gemacht
habecks gasumlage ist gescheitert
sein Ministerium arbeitet nun an einer
strompreisbremse
normalerweise würde man sich dafür zwei
oder drei Jahre Zeit nehmen so was
vorzubereiten zu diskutieren in
Expertenrunden ging es nicht zu halten
weil eben so viele Fehler passieren
können oder Auswirkungen passieren
können die man gar nicht intendiert hat
die Zeit haben wir nicht wir müssen es
in diesem Jahr machen wir auch wenn man
eigentlich denkt
eigentlich müssten wir noch mal eine
Testphase durchlaufen aber die Testphase
ist die Wirklichkeit im Moment
die Angst der Industrie vor einem
Blackout ist allgegenwärtig
[Musik]
weil jede Kilowattstunde zählt streitet
die Regierung monatelang über
Deutschlands letzte Atommeiler
[Musik]
ich bin der Überzeugung wir brauchen
alle Kernkraftwerke auch bis 2024 die
fossilen Energien
Inneren nicht die Lösung sie sind das
Problem schließlich beendet der Kanzler
den Streit mit einem Machtwort
Finanzminister Wirtschaftsminister und
Umweltministerin müssen sich fügen ich
wusste genau wann
es spätestens nötig ist die Entscheidung
zu treffen und nach dem es etwas
mühselig war eine Verständigung
herbeizuführen habe ich die
Möglichkeiten die das Grundgesetz mir
dazu gibt genutzt drei Atomkraftwerke
laufen weiter bis April 2023 es hat sehr
lange gedauert dass eigentlich
physikalisch notwendige zu erreichen
dass in diesem krisenwinter in Zeiten
eines energiekriegs alle Kapazitäten an
Kohlestrom und auch alle Kapazitäten an
Kernenergie am Netz bleiben das ist
eigentlich ein ein No-Brainer die ganz
überwiegende Mehrheit der Bevölkerung
will das jetzt haben wir eine
Entscheidung
und endlich haben wir eine Entscheidung
habe ich ja darauf hingewiesen die
entscheidungslosigkeit war das große
Problem
so können wir los es ist der Tag nach
dem sogenannten kanzlerbuster im
akw-streit der Oppositionsführer
schaltet auf Angriff
das ist schon eine außergewöhnliche Lage
ein Bundeskanzler der so explizit die
Richtlinienkompetenz in Anspruch nehmen
muss um einen Streit in der Koalition zu
lösen zieht sozusagen die letzte die
letzte vorletzte Möglichkeit aus dem
Köcher die letzte Möglichkeit ist die
Vertrauensfrage auf dem Weg zur
Fraktionssitzung trifft er die grüne
Umweltministerin Steffi Lemke zufällig
im Aufzug
kommen Sie rein mit uns geht's aufwärts
ich mache den Aufzug etwas schwerer
wollten sie sagen wenn ich mir ganz
sicher nein nein also auf die Kumpel
gehen wir noch
so dann fröhliches regieren ja
fröhliches politisiert
konstruktiv wollte Friedrich Merz die
Krise am Anfang begleiten Entscheidungen
mittragen jetzt sucht der
Oppositionsführer nach einer neuen Rolle
ist Mana Treiber Provokateur Winter
fängt an und die Menschen draußen im
Lande wissen nicht welche Hilfe sie
bekommen und das finde ich ist
eigentlich beschämend auch für die ganze
Politik in Deutschland keine gute Lösung
Regierung das sind jetzt die anderen und
war doch 16 Jahre lang die CDU unter
Angela Merkel es ist die Suche nach dem
Sündenbock wer trägt die Verantwortung
für Deutschlands Energiekrise
aus der Rückschau ist man immer klüger
und wenn wir alle gewusst hätten was
2022 geschieht dann hätten wir
spätestens 2014 begonnen unsere
Abhängigkeit von russischem Gas zu
reduzieren aber ich bin nicht bereit
dafür die alleinige Verantwortung bei
der Union zu suchen
das ist eine gemeinsame Fehleinschätzung
eine gemeinsame Abhängigkeit
verantwortete Abhängigkeit von
russischem Gas geworden die Folgen trägt
Deutschland heute tatsächlich
mehrheitlich gemeinsam
71% Antworten in unserer repräsentativen
Umfrage sie seien bereit die hohen
Energiepreise zu zahlen um die
angegriffene Ukraine weiter zu
unterstützen
der Kanzler reist im Herbst 2022 eilig
durch die Republik auf Zumutungen will
er das Land nicht vorbereiten Olaf
Scholz setzt auf ein weiter so
Wirtschaft Wachstum Wohlstand
ich bekenne mich ich werde alles dafür
tun dass unsere Volkswirtschaft weiter
wächst ich halte Wirtschaftswachstum für
unverzichtbar um unseren Wohlstand zu
sichern ist kann sein dass Gesellschaft
innerhalb von 20 Jahren ihre Position im
Wettbewerb der Gesellschaft und
verlieren das kann passieren das kann
ganz schnell passieren und ich glaube da
dukt sich unser Bundeskanzler zu sehr
weg
ich glaube ein bisschen er glaubt dass
er alles in der Hand hat aber der irrt
er sich
das Land für die Zukunft umbauen das ist
die große Aufgabe unserer Zeit
doch wer soll das in Deutschland
eigentlich machen
das Handwerk wieder fördern das Handwerk
ist nicht schlechtes ja und es muss auch
nicht jeder studieren wie kann ich
Auszubildenden
an locken um die Ausbildung zu starten
was kann ich attraktiv machen was kann
ich denn mit anbieten ja es gibt
eigentlich wenige die noch was machen
wollen die sagen dann immer das zu wenig
Geld und meint was ja auch manchmal auch
stimmt das ist unglaublich also ja es
ist unerhört was ich da haben wir nicht
vorgeplant haben wir es nicht gesehen
deutsches Handwerk und deutsche
Ingenieurskunst sie waren der Stolz
einer ganzen Nation eine Garantie für
unseren Wohlstand Menschen die tüfteln
anpacken Innovationen vorantreiben
andere pflegen doch inzwischen fehlen
sie fast überall laut Bundesagentur für
Arbeit hat sich die Zahl der offenen
Stellen in Deutschland seit 201 mehr als
verdoppelt
nach der corona-delle fehlen inzwischen
fast zwei Millionen Arbeitskräfte und
das ist erst der Anfang
zwischen ist es nicht mehr nur noch ein
Fachkräfteproblem an allen Ecken und
Enden des Arbeitsmarktes fehlen
Arbeitskräfte aufgrund der
demografischen Entwicklung werden wir
ein anderes Verhältnis eine immer
schlechteres Verhältnis der arbeitenden
Bevölkerung zu den Rentnerinnen und
Rentnern haben einfach weil die
geburtenstarken Jahrgänge jetzt alle
langsam in den Ruhestand gehen und
deswegen müssen wir uns mit dem Phänomen
auch massiv auseinandersetzen
Grafenau in Niederbayern
Handwerker wie Robert soppert sind es
die die Energiewende im Land umsetzen
Support baut Wärmepumpen ein auf dem
Dach dieses Einfamilienhauses liefert
eine Photovoltaikanlage den Strom dafür
hallo Gerhard grüß Dich so schauen wir
zu deiner Anlage
ja wunderbar sehr schön grün sehr schön
grün grün hast viele attackie mehr wir
haben einen 99% der Energie im Haus
erzeugen wir selber
die Gasheizung war mittlerweile 26 Jahre
alt es gab keine andere Alternative
meine Augen in der heutigen Zeit als zu
versuchen möglichst autark zu werden
die Bundesregierung will das Tempo bei
der Installation von Wärmepumpen
verdreifachen doch es gibt nicht
genügend Handwerker die sie einbauen
können
der Betrieb muss seine eigene
Mitarbeiter schulen und ausbilden das
ist
überhaupt nicht anders möglich
wichtig ist für uns dass dies in die
Breite Drogen wird dass das unendlich
interessant ist und dass der Handwerker
viele viele Möglichkeiten hat und nimmer
nur den akademischen Grad einschlägt
während kleine Betriebe aufgeben
versucht Robert sopper zu expandieren
hat 60 Angestellte gibt jeden zweiten
Freitag frei
doch auch er hat statt der erhofften
sechs Azubis dieses Jahr nur zwei
gefunden
glaube wir werden Zeiten erleben
da fällt eine Anlage aus und der Kunde
bekommt keinen Handwerker
wenn es so weitergeht werden in 25
Jahren zusätzlich 10 Millionen
Arbeitskräfte fehlen selbst wenn wir
später in Rente gehen und die
Erwerbsquote bei Frauen steigt während
es immer noch 8 Millionen rechnerisch
gibt es nur eine Lösung jährlich 400.000
Zuwanderer aus dem Ausland
tatsache aber ist es kommen zu wenige
Arbeitskräfte nach Deutschland als
Ursachen haben studienmangelnde
Chancengleichheit und Diskriminierung
ausgemacht leisten kann sich unser Land
das eigentlich nicht mein Gefühl ist
dass die Angst vor Zuwanderung immer
noch groß ist und dass sie eigentlich
derzeit aus einer wirtschaftlichen
Perspektive nicht so ganz berechtigt ist
wir sollten nicht kleinreden die
Probleme die mit die durch Zuwanderung
kommen aber wir sollten eben sehr sehr
stark sehen wie wichtig das ist und das
eben auch durchaus ein politisch
kommunizieren und eben dass es für
unseren Arbeitsmarkt ganz unverzichtbar
ist
laut unserer Umfrage sehen 63% der
deutschen das inzwischen genauso und
sind für mehr Zuwanderung von
Arbeitskräften
Robert soppard sucht in Ungarn nach
neuen Mitarbeitern für seine Firma auf
neue Wärmepumpen und Solardächer müssen
seine Kunden derzeit lange warten
wir würden frühestens nichts zu im
Februar März an vor ortem Besuchstermin
haben vorher sah man immer frei und dann
wird es für die Umsetzung sicher Name
ein paar Monate dauern bis das mal an
die Reihe kommt wegen der Vorlaufzeit
wir haben uns sicher alleine jetzt für
dieses Jahr weit als eine Verdopplung im
Markt dass man aber mit gleicher
Mannschaft stemmen
mit gleicher Mannschaft damit wird der
notwendige Umbau unserer Gesellschaft
nicht zu schaffen sein
an einem Samstag im Oktober 2022 ist der
Kanzler nach München gekommen um sich
über zukunftsjobs im Handwerk zu
informieren auch hier ist der
Fachkräftemangel sofort Thema
dann haben sie schon genug Leute die das
alles können
nein die Leute die Leute können das und
und die sind auch hoch motiviert wir
bräuchten nur mehr ja gut aber ich
glaube wir müssen zur schönsten Station
ohne moderne Heiztechnik von
Spezialisten installiert wird es mit der
Energiewende nicht klappen wir brauchen
viel mehr die das tun gerade in dem
berufen die jetzt wichtig sind für
unsere Energiewende wenn wir
Solarpaneele auf Dächern installieren
wollen muss irgendjemand aufs Dach und
die fachliche Kompetenz haben das gut
und richtig zu machen und darüber hinaus
werden wir neben den
fegen Absolventen unserer Universitäten
und Hochschulen auch Frauen und Männer
aus der ganzen Welt überzeugen müssen
dass sie ihr Talent bei uns entfalten
und zu unserem Wohlstand beitragen
dürfen ihnen kleinen Glücksbringer
überreichen ihre Vorgängerinnen hatte
den auch auf dem Schreibtisch stehen wir
wünschen Ihnen alles Gute für die
Herausforderungen
herzlichen Zeit nehmen schönen Dank
glücksbringer sind keine Strategie die
aber braucht ein Land in dem gerade eine
Illusion nach der anderen platzt was das
Land auch braucht eine Infrastruktur die
funktioniert
[Musik]
Deutschland spart sich manchmal kaputt
ich kann nicht von von A nach B einfach
irgendwo einsteigen und hinfahren also
ich bin auch aufs Auto angewiesen wenn
ich mit dem Bus auf die Arbeit fahren
könnte würde ich es tun tut mir leid die
Bahn ist für mich keine Alternative
jetzt abgefahren
eigentlich ist es ganz einfach ein
zukunftsfähiges Land braucht
Stromtrassen schnelle Datenleitungen und
ein gutes Verkehrssystem für Menschen
und waren
das Besondere an Infrastruktur wir
nehmen sie erst wahr wenn sie mal wieder
nicht funktioniert
die Verödung der Infrastruktur ist
wirklich ein Problem das ist auch ganz
interessant die öffentlich Verwaltung
sind gar nicht mehr darauf eingestellt
dass man ihn fast Struktur neu errichten
muss wir sehen das dass sehr viel Geld
da ist was nicht für ausgab wird man
steht davor und irgendwie kann das sein
die Konsequenz die Deutsche Bahn wird
nicht besser sondern immer unpünktlicher
seit Jahren kommt etwa jeder fünfte Zug
zu spät im August 2022 waren nur noch
56,8% der Fernzüge pünktlich
auf den maroden Autobahnen geht es nicht
schneller die Staulänge pro Jahr hat
sich zwischen 2002 und 2019 fast
verfünffacht selbst in den corona-jahren
gab es immer noch mehr als doppelt so
viele Staus wie 2002
[Musik]
in unserer Umfrage waren 68% der Meinung
das zu wenig in Infrastruktur investiert
wird
so ist zum Beispiel der Zustand jeder
neunten deutschen Autobahnbrücke
schlecht
mit bitteren Folgen wie hier in
Lüdenscheid über die Rahmede Brücke
fährt seit Dezember niemand mehr bekam
mein Handyanruf von der Direktorin der
Autobahn Westfalen die sich dann
vorstellt und sagte ich wir haben die
Brücke untersucht und wir haben
erhebliche Mängel festgestellt und ich
beabsichtige die Brücke innerhalb der
nächsten halben Stunde voll zu sperren
so und dann sitzen sie erstmal hier und
sind auch überfordert weil das kommt wie
eine Naturkatastrophe über sie
65.000 Fahrzeuge fuhren bis dahin
durchschnittlich jeden Tag über die
Brücke die Umleitung führt mitten durch
die Stadt allein 6500 LKW täglich machen
seitdem das Leben zum Albtraum
sogar der Verkehrsminister aus Berlin
ist schon ins verkehrskatastrophengebiet
geeilt um die Gemüter zu beruhigen doch
der permanente Verkehrskollaps lässt
sich nicht wegreden
wenn ich jetzt mal eben kurz irgendwo
hin möchte die Kinder wollen vielleicht
meinen Sportverein das geht gar nicht
mehr ich kann nicht vier Stunden mal der
Lebenszeit am Tag für diese scheiß
Umleitung aufbauen wenn wir jetzt
irgendwelche Termine haben dann überlegt
man mittlerweile ganz gezielt was könnte
man auf dieser Strecke noch erledigen
weil morgen oder übermorgen möchte ich
das nicht noch mal fahren Anfang der
1970er war es Willy Brandt der die
Sauerlandlinie feierlich dem Verkehr
übergab die A45 sie war ein
zukunftsversprechen eine Schlagader des
wirtschaftlichen Aufschwungs für eine
ganze Region nur 53 statt der geplanten
100 Jahre hat die Rahmede Brücke
gehalten dass sie renovierungsbedürftig
war das war bekannt ein Neubau wurde
sogar schon geplant doch dann wieder
verschoben das bringt jetzt hunderte
Betriebe in schweren Not auch das
Märkische Federwerk das ein paar hundert
Meter von der Brücke entfernt liegt
[Musik]
wir machen Risikobewertung und
Notfallpläne für alle Dinge Hochwasser
feuerausfall von Lieferanten Auswahl von
Materialien aber das eine Straße und so
dermaßen zum Erliegen bringen könnte das
hat sich glaube ich nie einer denken
können
Federn die heute hier gefertigt werden
brauchen andere Unternehmen teilweise
schon am nächsten Tag deshalb muss
pünktlich geliefert werden jetzt droht
was eigentlich alle verhindern wollten
für besonders zeitkritische Produkte ist
das Lüdenscheider Werk zu unsicher
wir werden hier Artikel raus verlagern
an unseren Hauptstandort nach Anröchte
und Erwitte an unsere Schwester company
in Polen einfach um den Nachteilen die
wir hier im Moment sehen und lieber
absehbar für die nächsten Jahre sehen
irgendwie entgegentreten zu können
der wirtschaftliche Schaden durch die
aufgeschobene Brückensanierung ist noch
gar nicht absehbar sicher ist das Sparen
in der Vergangenheit wird jetzt
unfassbar teuer
wir befinden uns jetzt natürlich in der
viel viel schwierigeren Lage um diese
verpassten Verbesserungsmaßnahmen und
Ausbaumaßnahmen im Bereich Infrastruktur
aufzuholen als es noch vor ein paar
Jahren der Fall gewesen wäre
der Neubau wird fünf Jahre dauern
inklusive Prüfungen Planungs- und
Genehmigungsverfahren Deutschland 2022
ein träges Bürokratiemonster
[Musik]
das alles zusammen ist schon
eine erhebliche Gefährdung glaube ich
für den gesamten Wohlstand unseres
Landes jetzt nicht nur was also die
Brücke hier in Lüdenscheid kann man
sicherlich auch als ein Stück Symbol
Symbol Kraft nehmen für den Zustand der
Infrastrukturen ganz vielen Teilen
dieses Landes wir werden alle
Anstrengungen unternehmen müssen unsere
Infrastruktur auszubauen und auch auf
den neuesten Stand zu bringen kommt das
deutsche wohlstandsmodell an sein Ende
oder gelingt in der Krise die Erneuerung
des Landes Oktober 22
Wirtschaftsminister Harbeck empfängt den
Industrieminister aus den Vereinigten
Arabischen Emiraten der erste Container
mit blauem Wasserstoff aus dem Golfstaat
ist eingetroffen aus fossilem Erdgas
gewonnen ein klimaschädlicher Kompromiss
der grüne Vizekanzler geht ihn ein
wir machen etwas in wenigen Jahren was
so was wie eine Neugründung der
deutschen wirtschaftlichen Kraft ist das
ist von Experten wird es manchmal
verglichen mit der Aufbauphase nach dem
Zweiten Weltkrieg aber da war halt alles
kaputt
was in vielen Jahrzehnten versäumt wurde
muss in kurzer Zeit nachgeholt werden
die Frage ist heute wie viel können wir
an Wohlstand aufrechterhalten wie viel
müssen wir aufrecht erhalten
für unsere Demokratie für unsere
Grundwerte und wie wird das hinkriegen
ohne ökologische Zerstörung es gibt in
unserem Land aber auch viele die gar
nicht so viel haben und ich glaube da
kommt es darauf an diese Menschen auch
zu stärken mitzunehmen denen müssen wir
auch ein neues wohlstandsversprechen
geben ich will überhaupt nicht
optimistisch aber ich habe Hoffnung also
wenn Sie so wollen Hoffnung ohne jeden
Optimismus
Deutschland wird sich verändern aber wie
wir können uns auch einmal eine gewisse
Zeit des Rückgangs unseres Wohlstandes
leisten was das mit uns als Gesellschaft
macht ist ein ja fast schon ein
Experiment ich denke das ist diesen
Winter noch gar nicht so das Problem
wird ich denke Schwier jetzt erst so den
nächsten Winter unsere Kinder wenn ich
auch meine Enkelkinder beobachte die
lernen damit umzugehen genau wie wir
nach dem Krieg gelernt haben mit dem
Aufbau umzugehen es geht jetzt um den
Aufbruch in eine ungewisse Zeit
[Musik]
das deutsche wenn man so sagen will
Geschäftsmodell verändert sich und das
erfordert ein neues Denken von uns ich
befürchte schon dass es uns jetzt
ziemlich
in der Welt
zurückwirft wir werden eine Delle haben
ja wie lange die dauert weiß kein Mensch
vielleicht ein halbes Jahr vielleicht
zwei Jahre keine Ahnung aber dann bin
ich sicher dass es wieder nach vorwärts
geht
bleibt die Gesellschaft zusammen auch
wenn der Kit des Wohlstands fehlt
haben wir in den letzten Jahren noch
relativ sind wir doch gut durch die Zeit
gekommen manchmal zu gut und wenn wir
mal ein bisschen das abgeben müssen für
etwas wo wir hinter stehen habe ich das
Gefühl es wäre gut für uns alle
deutschland ist ein Land das angesichts
einer
großen Herausforderungen
alles dafür getan hat mit dieser auch
fertig zu werden und es wird unser Land
nicht nur nach vorne bringen sondern
auch verändern
Deutschland das ist jetzt ein Land in
dem abends die Lichter ausgehen um
Energie zu sparen
ein Land das sich neu erfinden muss
ein Land im Umbruch
[Musik]